well e.t has learned kim and pete are
making a date night at the met gala all
that karjenner sisters arrived in new
york yesterday courtney and travis flew
in from italy and this morning courtney
kicked off the day with a facial i ran
into pete davidson at the met and i was
like i am so scared i don't know what i
signed up for and he's like can you read
cue cards you're good you're good
yeah kim and pete met at lester's mets
where he calmed her fears about hosting
snl and speaking of hosting blake lively
and ryan reynolds are official co-chairs
for the gala along with lin-manuel
miranda and regina king this is regina's
first public appearance since the death
of her son ian in january and her third
time at the big event the dress code
this year is gilded glamour and white
tie so what does that mean exactly well
think ruffles lace bows and corsets kind
of like the hbo drama the gilded age
let the tournament begin i think anna
was very keen to make it more formal i
think from other years wait no
hamburgers and chandeliers no
chandeliers no cars or yeah yeah we come
up with the idea of gilded age glamour
so i think we'll see a lot of
gold i think the met by the numbers
there are 500 guests but we're told
don't expect to see jlo tickets are
around 30 thousand dollars each the
tables are 275 000 but you can't just
buy your way in and winter hand-picks
the attendees just a few blocks away
from here is the mark hotel where most
of the stars get ready and only team is
with singer and actress janelle monae
that's just the way you make me feel
i'm like this is the most
dressed down i think i've ever allowed
anybody to see me in 2019 janelle wore
this blinking picasso inspired gown this
year the star is donnie ralph lauren i
looked at some of their archives and i'd
seen a look that i really loved but i
was like what if we made it in the
future
rain or shine tonight is going to be a
feast for the fashion senses